the Avengers the movie right so it's not
new news if this movie is happening but
I haven't done a video on it because
until now the news has just been that
it's happening but now this Avengers
movie almost has a director and I think
that's worth talking about because this
almost director happens to be Joss
Whedon
yeah the Serenity Firefly Buffy Angel
dollhouse that Joss Whedon and I guess
the announcement that Joss Whedon was in
final talks to direct the Avengers movie
came out on April 1st which is kind of
stupid because they were like oh hey
April Fool's Day oh by the way Joss
Whedon might just direct the Avengers
movie and everyone was like yeah okay
April Fool's Day to you two
for not buying it and that was been like
two weeks and they're like dude we're
serious Joss Whedon might just direct
the Avengers movie and so now we can
believe it because honestly no one lives
that much unless you're a politician or
OJ and so now I'm compelled to put my
two cents in on the subject okay so
first of all if you've seen my videos
namely the dollhouse is canceled screw
Fox video you know I'm a big Joss Whedon
fan so right off the bat you can pretty
much know that I'm liking him for the
choice to direct the Avengers movie but
I'd like to think that I'd be objective
enough to protest the idea if I thought
it was a idea like if Joss Whedon
were set to direct the Breaking Dawn
movie I would like to think I'd be like
that is a stupid call Joss Whedon should
not do that
then again I think if Christopher Nolan
were set to direct the Breaking Dawn
movie from a screenplay penned by Peter
Jackson I'd probably still Pro dozed it
because there's just no need for
Twilight I mean not ever but as it
happens I think Joss Whedon is a really
good choice to direct the Avengers movie
and I'll tell you why it's because of
all the characters Joss Whedon has
proven time and time again that his
strength and storytelling comes with an
ensemble of different characters the guy
has a knack for taking a bunch of
characters making them all relevant
making them all matter and making you
care about each individual one making
them all individual functioning pieces
of a larger body as it were that I don't
give you if that was kind of cheesy
that was a good metaphor I mean
let's face it he directs those funny
sarcastic yet really badass characters
really well so I think Iron Man's safe
and he understands that a crew of
individuals working towards a common
goal but seeing things through different
perspectives causes friction so I'm
thinking we're gonna see some Iron Man
Captain America clashing going on I mean
honestly up to this point I've only seen
this Avengers movie as some sort of cash
grab like a way to make a bunch of cash
by slapping a bunch of comic-book heroes
in the same movie together kind of like
that Justice League movie was gonna be
with a rapper playing the Green Lantern
but now I'm thinking it could be a
really strong story about their
characters that have to work together as
a team who happened to have the
little task of saving the world you know
those little things in life pin again as
of now Joss Whedon's in final talks
which means tomorrow Joss Whedon could
be totally out and George Lucas could be
in so he can rape and kill yet another
franchise only difference is it'll be a
franchise that he didn't actually start
to begin with that's right George we're
just never gonna forgive you for that
just not ever but Fox isn't doing it so
maybe Joss Whedon will stick around on
this one so Joss Whedon directing the
Avengers are you feeling it are you not
feeling it comment below let me know and
have you seen the Joss Whedon thing
before because if you haven't I've said
it before and I'll say it now Firefly
watch Firefly have I steered you guys
wrong have I steered you wrong alright
granted we're not always gonna agree on
everything but I'll tell you right now
Firefly is probably better than any
movie I've seen in the last year because
if he can pull that feeling off in an
Avengers movie
it's got my vote so comment below and
let me know after you watch Firefly
[Music]